foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
good morning afternoon evening
I may be in the movie capital of the
world but movies really live wherever
you come together in theaters or in your
homes to share great stories told on the
screen and today we celebrate that
thanks to the nearly 9 500 voting
members of The Academy their Movie
Makers sure but really movie lovers
about to share the films they've loved
the most this year
I hope you're doing the same with your
friends and your family Now's the Time
movie lovers Unite
let's meet your announcement hosts Tracy
Ellis Ross and Leslie Jordan
[Music]
I am so excited I went to sleep dressed
like this
now let's go to the Oscars Tracy what
time are you picking me up uh oh Leslie
someone did not read the memo the Oscars
are not tonight they're on March 27th
this morning we just announced the
nominees
this is why I hate being hunkered down I
never know what day it is or month
but if it's not the Oscars why are you
dressed so nice oh oh this this old
thing this is my workout outfit Leslie I
just threw this on to go to cycling
class in an hour
all right this year's Oscars theme is
movie lovers unite and during this next
half hour we will be joined by some very
special movie lovers across the country
to help us announce some of the nominees
are you ready Leslie wait I'll be right
back this outfit it doesn't feel right
for the Oscar announcements okay all
right well
Oscar nominees in most categories are
chosen by members of their respective
branches but nominees for Best Picture
are chosen by the entire Academy
membership and if you stay tuned to find
out how this year you the fans will be
able to get to vote for your favorite
movie and movie moment featured on the
Oscar telecast
now I'm ready
I love it understated and traditional
very much under the nominees for
performance by an actress in a
supporting role
Jesse Buckley in the Lost daughter
Ariana Dubose in West Side Story
Judy Dench in Belfast
Kirsten Dunst in power of the dog
and ingenu Ellis in King Richard
my turn
hear the nominees for achievement in
costume design
Cruella
Sarah no
on
nightmare Ally
and West Side Story
I'm a little hurt my costume wasn't
nominated again well maybe next year
here are the nominees for achievement in
sound
Belfast
Dune
no time to die
the power of the dog
and West Side Story
as part of our movie lovers uniting
across the country let's go to Troy
Michigan joining us are 11 Healthcare
professionals from Beaumont Hospital
reading the nominees is physician's
assistant and fellow movie lover shantia
Bobo Hardin who loves the movie Girl
trip shantia over to you
thank you Tracy here are the nominees
for achievement in music original score
don't look up
Dune
Encanto
parallel mothers
and the power of the dog
thank you so much shantia and thank you
to all the health care workers at
Beaumont and all across the country who
do so much for all of us thank you
Leslie Leslie wait is that an is that an
official Oscar pendant and if so why
didn't I get one
I borrowed it from your Oscar
nominations gift basket ah okay and now
adapted screenplay the nominees are
coda
screenplay by Sean Haider
scream I ryusuke hamuguchi
and taka Masa owa
Dune
screenplay by John Spades
Dinuba
de Nouveau New and Eric Roth
the Lost daughter written by Maggie
Gyllenhaal
and the power of the dog written by Jane
Campion
here are the nominees for original
screenplay
Belfast written by Kenneth Branagh
don't look up
screenplay by Adam McKay Story by Adam
McKay and David Sirota
King Richard written by Zach Balon
licorice pizza written by Paul Thomas
Anderson
and the worst person in the world
written by S kill vacht and you are Kim
Trier
here are the nominees for best animated
short film
Affairs of the
Bestia
box ballet
Robin
and the windshield wiper
another category for me back to back
Leslie again I think they like my
announcer voice and now the nominees for
best live action short film well done
alakachu take and run
the dress
the long goodbye
on my mind
and please hold
it's so appropriate that I just
announced animated short film and live
action short for I am animated
and short
oh Leslie and now here are the nominees
for performance by an actor in a
supporting role
Karine Hines in Belfast
Troy kotzer in coda
Jesse plemons in the power of the dog
JK Simmons in being the Ricardos
and Cody Smith McPhee in power of the
dog
in just a few minutes we've got more
nominee announcements coming up
including those four lead actor and
actress director and best picture
foreign
how much fun is this this is the most
fun I have ever had at 5 25 in the
morning
not
you can tell that Leslie and I are
bristling we are bristling with
diversity we are bringing diversity to
these announcements I am moderna and I
am sparkling Pfizer Leslie are you
boosted why yes Tracy I'm sitting on a
pillow
okay joining us is another movie lover
film Enthusiast Rhys Feldman Reese
what's your reaction to the nominees for
supporting actress tell us everything
um this is such a stacked category uh I
love it so much Jesse Buckley for the
Lost daughter I've really loved her and
I'm thinking of anything so I'm really
um excited that she's getting recognized
for this
um although Olivia Coleman's getting a
lot of praise for her performance in
this movie uh it's Jesse Buckley who
helps move the story forward into from
the past um so she's just incredible
Ariana Dubose hearing her name announced
really just made me smile
um simply put she's perfect as Anita in
West Side Story and for a character
that's already won Rita Moreno and Oscar
60 years prior it's just so incredible
to me that she was able to step into
this role and just make it entirely her
own
um Dame Judy Dench for Belfast um
seven-time Oscar nominee already won
back in 98 for Shakespeare in Love she's
just so dialed in throughout this entire
film and just plays great off of Kieran
Hines and I'm kind of excited to see her
maybe get a second win Kirsten Dunst for
the power of the dog this was one I was
really hoping for I mean that piano
scene and gosh she is such a talent and
I really hope this is the role that
she's going to be remembered for moving
forward and I think the success of the
movie largely deals with how good she is
and lastly uh but definitely not least
anjanu Ellis she has been consistently
amazing in every role that she's been in
for decades and although she plays a
supporting role in King Richard
um she really does feel like an
additional lead next to Will Smith for
just how much power she brings to the
performance so it was just a great
category
um
what's your take on the costume nominees
or on my costume
yours is fantastic and it's the biggest
snip here it should have been nominated
but yes Cruella honestly a really fun
surprise of a movie of 2021 and
obviously the costumes are such a focus
it's a fashion movie uh the 70s London
just does so much for it and every dress
genuinely looks like it deserves to be
at the Met Gala uh Cyrano I'm a sucker
for period pieces and the fact that it
takes place in 17th century France just
feels like it was written for me
um the formal wear uh the military
uniforms the the design of the play is
it's all just so good uh Dune I think is
such a cool nomination because it's a
sci-fi movie and I like it's really
tough to submerge a viewer in the
reality
um of the film and because of the
costume it kind of grounds Us in this
futuristic reality it's advanced yet
familiar
um nightmare alley uh I really liked
that
um
it's just so many different settings the
carnival scenes are great and the
costuming and that is wonderful and the
worlds that Guillermo del Toro crafts
um the costumes absolutely match it and
the whole look of the film is wonderful
and lastly West Side Story uh this film
60 years prior has already won an Oscar
for costume design and I really wouldn't
be surprised if it wins again
um the costumes the color the attention
to detail the way that each costume kind
of speaks to the characters as
individuals it's really just uh one of
the many reasons why I love that movie
so much this year
what categories are you most excited to
see coming up
oh I I've been dying to see who's going
to get nominated for best picture that's
that's one I've been waiting the whole
year for
and do you see any Trends do you see any
Trends developing anything that's you
can give us cue us into
I don't know I feel like it's too early
to say I I really love who's been
nominated but
I'm I'm interested to see I guess also
best film editing that's one that I
always love to look out for and I'm
always interested to have the academy
voters
um decide
um so that's definitely another one that
I'm kind of really looking forward to
well thank you so much Reese it's really
been fun hearing your take on all of
this and we'll be checking back in with
you later
sounds great
so uh Leslie how's it feeling on your
side feeling good yeah yeah
thank you
seems so rushed
hearing your name announce this morning
is a moment
each nominee will never forget not that
I would know what an Oscar nomination is
like but a Boy Can Dream oh Leslie and a
girl can dream too for those Hunker
downers just joining us good morning
good morning and for those who have been
watching welcome back all right now it
is time for the rest of the Oscar
nomination announcements including the
big one at the end for big picture
here are the nominees for achievement
and film editing
don't look up
Dune
King Richard
the power of the dog
and Tick Tick boom
why Leslie don't you look beautiful
well thank you Tracy awesome I get to
announce everyone up for achievement and
makeup and hair styling none of whom
showed up at my house this morning I did
this all myself you did yeah now here
are the nominees
Coming to America
Cruella
Dune
the eyes of Tammy Faye
and House of Gucci
and now it is time to meet a huge movie
fan coming to us from Tampa a huge movie
fan and a huge guy well to me everyone
is huge oh Leslie he is a WWE Superstar
who established the award-winning
Thaddeus M Bullard Academy at Sly Middle
Magnet School the Academy's mission is
to serve economically disadvantaged
students by providing them with a first
class education and creating a wonderful
culture of positivity here is Titus
O'Neal
thanks Tracy and Leslie to read the
names of the nominees in this next
category is a fellow movie lover 8th
grade track star high honor roll student
Courtney Anderson who loves the entire
Twilight movie series Courtney take it
away
here are the nominees for the best
animated feature film
Encanto
flee
Luca
the Mitchells versus the machine
and Raya and the Lost Dragon
well done
[Music]
Titus Courtney and all those amazing
students for joining us and now here are
the nominees for achievement in music
original song
be alive from King Richard
as from Encanto
down to Joy from Belfast
no time to die from no time to die
and somehow you do from four good days
the category is best documentary short
oh you're making me do the short
category again I didn't do it it wasn't
me it was you it was you here are the
nominees for best documentary short
subject
Audible
lead me home
the queen of basketball
three songs for Ben azir
and when we were bullies
and now here are the nominees for best
documentary feature
Ascension
Attica
flee
summer of Soul or when the revolution
could not be televised
and riding with fire
joining us from Times Square are New
York's bravest members of the fire
department of New York at the microphone
is fellow movie fan lieutenant Thomas
Carrera whose favorite movie is
Goodfellas
thank you Leslie and Tracy coming to you
live from Times Square here are the
nominees for achievement and visual
effects
the envelope please
Doom
free guy
no time to die
and the legend of the ten rings
Spider-Man
no way home
thank you so much to all the
firefighters paramedics and EMTs for all
that you do I wave every time you drive
by I say hello firefighters I really do
next up the nominees for achievement in
cinematography
Dune
nightmare alley
the power of the dog
the tragedy of Macbeth and West Side
Story
and now here are the nominees for
achievement in production design
Dune
nightmare Ally
the power of the dog
the tragedy of Macbeth
and West Side Story
god let's see are you
are you wearing something different
again just cause I'm hunkered down
doesn't mean I can't dress up okay so
here are the nominees for best
International feature film drive my car
Japan
flee Denmark
the hand of God Italy
Luana a yak in the classroom Bhutan
and the worst person in the world Norway
Leslie you keep stealing all my lines
there's one for you okay thanks let's
head to Ira Aldridge theater at Howard
University in Washington DC where we
have a special presenter Felicia Rashad
is Dean of the Chadwick a Bozeman
college of fine arts and joins us with
some of her students hello
hello and thank you Leslie and Tracy all
of our students here are so inspired by
Chadwick Boseman Howard grad who was so
committed to this University and as you
know Chadwick was nominated last year
for best actor and we are so honored to
announce the nominees in this category
speaking on behalf of the students who
are with us today is a senior who's
receiving his BFA in acting John Woods
III
the nominees for performance by an actor
in a leading role are
Javier Bardem in being the Ricardos
Benedict's Cumberbatch in the power of
the dog
Andrew Garfield in Tick Tick boom
Will Smith and King Richard
in Denzel Washington in the tragedy of
Macbeth yes
[Applause]
yes well done beautiful thank you
Felicia and John and all of the students
who joined us today
and now the nominees for performance by
an actress in a leading role
Jessica Chastain in the eyes of Tammy
Faye
Olivia Coleman in the Lost daughter
Penelope Cruz and parallel mothers
Nicole Kidman in being the Ricardos
and Kristen Stewart in Spencer
just two more categories left
this is so exciting the first is for
achievement in directing and the
nominees are
Kenneth Branagh Belfast
Ray yusuke hamuguche drive my car
Paul Thomas Anderson licorice pizza
Jane Campion the power of the dog
and Steven Spielberg West Side Story
and finally the big one
here are the nominees for Best Picture
Belfast Laura Berwick Kenneth Branagh
Becca kuvasik and Tamar Thomas producers
coda Philippe Russell Fabrice giafermi
and Patrick
waxberger producer
the producers
don't look up Adam McKay and Kevin
Messick producers
drive my car
ohisa Yamamoto producer
Dune Mary parent
denu Villeneuve
and kale boiter
producers
King Richard Tim White Trevor White and
Will Smith producers
licorice pizza Sarah Murphy Adam somner
and Paul Thomas Anderson producers
nightmare alley Guillermo del Toro J
milesdale and Bradley Cooper producers
the power of the dog Jane Campion
Tanya
Tanya segacian sorry Emil Sherman Ian
canning and Roger Frappier producers
and West Side Story Steven Spielberg and
Christy mccosko Krieger producers
10 great Best Picture nominees everybody
please make sure to watch the Oscars on
March 27th on ABC and go to oscars.org
to learn how you can vote to get your
favorite movie and movie moment featured
on this year's Oscar telecast it was so
exciting to wake up with you Tracy I
can't wait for Oscar and I you're the
best Leslie oh what a treat you are and
the best part you're already dressed to
them
and now let's hear from professional
bring in bring in Reese
Reese Feldman if you are ready for us
we can go through the best picture
nominees because we are dying to hear
from you
I am so so so excited about every
picture that's nominated this is exactly
what I wanted to hear um to start off
Kenneth Bruno's Belfast uh it's such a
deeply personal film and it reads
through every shot in the movie
um and he angles it through uh the lens
of like adolescence and it really just
paints this really sweet portrait of a
family in an otherwise tumultuous time
in Northern Ireland's history uh Coda I
really love when incredibly Charming
films like this one get recognized by
the academy
um also while sound of metal was a solid
stepping point for the deaf community's
representation in film Koda really
drives home the point that these stories
need to be told and need to get made and
it's easily one of my favorites from the
year if you haven't seen it definitely
watch it
don't look up another one where I really
just love when comedies get recognized
by the academy and of course when the
movie is headlined by Leonardo DiCaprio
Jennifer Lawrence Merrell Streep you
know it was going to be good and while
the comedic bits are awesome I really do
love those introspective dramatic beats
like the final dinner scene just
wonderful
drive my car this is one that I I'm
grinning ear to ear because of this
nomination the Japanese film industry
has always been and remains to be such a
Powerhouse of Cinema
um and out of all the movies I've seen
this year it's definitely the most
atmospheric and it's three hour run time
although long uh it's just every shot in
it you could just tell it's nothing
short of perfect
I am very excited that I'm alive at the
same time as Disney Villeneuve
um just because he is such an ambitious
filmmaker and every one of his films is
just a masterpiece he just churns out
hit after hit and dune he just
effectively brings this amazing story
right off the page and it translates
perfectly onto the screen
when I first heard that they were doing
a Venus Williams and Serena Williams
biopic I thought it was going to be the
normal route but when I watched King
Richard I was so pleasantly surprised it
was from the perspective of their father
and it was such a brilliant choice at a
hundred percent Works
um it's just like a really great biopic
with a particularly interesting glance
into a brief time before we knew who
they were
now Paul Thomas Anderson is uh he's
always great and licorice pizza is
nothing short of great and I really love
the fact that not only is it a
coming-of-age movie but that he cast two
new actors as the leads um and their
acting doesn't read as inexperienced at
all but instead reads as raw and genuine
and it just works for the movie
now this next one I'm a big fan of the
original uh nightmare alley from 1947
with Tyrone Power is great
um so when I heard that they were
remaking it I was a little nervous but
of course gamma Del Toro is just a
genius and he adds his own creativity to
the film and I guess his expertise on
horror really helped this thriller just
go over the top and be so good uh Jane
Campion I love all of her work but I
really feel like this is her magnum opus
she combines uh the aesthetic beauty of
a John Ford Western in power of the dog
with this deeply intimate look into like
the interesting power dynamics of a
family from the ponzine to the Rope
scene it's it's all just so good and
then lastly but definitely not least
West Side Story
um it's such a great movie Steven
Spielberg is obviously one of the best
directors to ever live and he takes on
such a familiar story but adds so much
of his own Flair to it and it just works
in the best way possible he makes the
story his own and it's easily one of my
favorites from this past year
this has been so much fun they should
put us in a sitcom remake oh I agree I
can see it now the really Odd Couple oh
my God Leslie can you imagine the
Wardrobe budget we would look amazing
how about we make a buddy cop movie he's
the small time Sheriff from Tennessee
who came to the big city and she's the
tough talking cop from the wild streets
of Beverly Hills oh my gosh I can smell
it I smell Oscar 2023 until then
everybody thank you for joining us and
congratulations to all of the nominees
make sure to watch this year's Academy
Awards on Sunday March 27th on ABC and
what a treat to spend this early morning
with you thank you thank you Leslie yes
I can't wait for us to reunite oh soon
[Music]